this video is sponsored by
brilliant I want to push myself to do
hard things although the first hard
thing is walking and carrying all of
these textbooks here in one
hand I've locked myself in a b out in
the Australian bush with no phone no
Internet just a bunch of textbooks about
fractals and I can't leave until I
master this
[Music]
topic I know a little bit about rectals
already but not a lot I know that they
are these self similar shapes that can
appear a lot in nature I know one
example would be something like a fern
plant where it's got like that main
branching shap shape which is similar to
each of the little leaves and and they
have this similar repeating pattern at
multiple levels actually I've just seen
that there's this Fern like shape here
although it's a plastic one but this is
what I mean that this main shape here
looks similar to each of these little
individual ones I know of some of the
famous fractals you can draw and I do
know that not all fractals are self-
similar that it doesn't have to be the
same pattern repeating at multiple
scales but that there is some detail at
multiple
scales so let me give you a bus tour
we've got the door the window and the
driver's seat here I have my stuff my
camera and a bunch of textbooks I got
out from the library before coming here
a little outside deck although I'm not
allowed to go out there may I introduce
you to the food that I have for this
challenge these tins of beans right here
are it these are my rations I have a
producer who is going to test my
knowledge by slipping some envelopes
with questions under the door and if I
get them correct then I get rewards that
help to make studying easier and if I
get five correct I get to
leave we've got stuff about fractal
Dimensions fractals in geology and
geophysics this one sounds interesting
fractal space time and microphysics the
beauty of fractals what shape is a
snowflake magical number in nature
fractals and multifractals in ecology
and Aquatic science but the book I'm
most looking forward to read is this one
over here this is mandal br's book on
fractals it's called the fractal
geometry of Nature and since mandal BR
was the guy who came up with fractal
pretty much or first communicated them I
think this one is going to have a lot of
really special knowledge in it mandal BR
opens with why is geometry often
described as cold and dry one reason
lies in its inability to describe the
shape of a cloud a mountain a coastline
or a tree clouds are not spheres
mountains are not cones Coast lines are
not circles and bark is not smooth nor
does lightning travel in a straight line
Mand says that there is a Latin saying
that to name is to know and he names
these complex natural patterns fractals
one of the first examples of a fractal
that mandal BR gives is the coastline
Paradox the co Co line is surprisingly
hard to measure the length of because
there is detail at every level zooming
all the way down to the atomic sizes if
you used a small ruler and measured
around every rock you would get a much
larger answer than if you used say a th
km sized ruler to measure it there are a
couple of different ways of measuring
the dimension of something the first is
topological Dimension which is an
integer value reflecting the number of
coordinates needed to specify a point
within the space it's intuitive and
straightforward with lines being
one-dimensional and planes
two-dimensional and so forth another way
is the horse or fractal Dimension which
extends Beyond integers to include
fractional values and is a Cornerstone
of fractals it quantifies the degree to
which a fractal fills space this page
shows some data of measuring the length
of coastlines in different places can
see that the coast of Britain is
especially steep in this regard compared
to attempts to measure the South African
Coast they stabilized off a bit more and
a circle which isn't fractal it's just
an ordinary shape that stabilizes pretty
quickly and so it doesn't matter if you
use a smaller ruler to measure the
circle you're going to for the most part
get the same result perhaps this means
that the coast of Britain is especially
fract and Mandel BR says down here that
he had the idea of using the slope of
these lines as an estimate of 1us D
where D is the fractal Dimension I've
just seen a wild dear I don't know I've
never seen one before in Australia I
might follow it and go have a
look there it
is I actually love staring out of a bus
window just sitting there um watching
the world go by usually um but this is a
stationary view which is a bit different
I think some of my best thoughts that
I've had have just been you know sitting
on a bus or a car just like looking out
the window I could do that for ages I am
starting to really stress actually
because I don't know when the first
question is going to arrive and it could
be any minute so I'm kind of on edge and
that's not helping me to absorb the
information I've been reading for a
couple of hours now and I feel like I
don't really know if I've learned
anything
new the anxiety that I'm feeling now is
kind of hitting at why I was motivated
to do this challenge um which is like
this fear of mine that I'm becoming not
very good at doing hard things that even
my focus is it feels like it's not as
good as it used to be I want to feel
like I do have a good grasp on a lot of
topics so that I can talk about them My
worry is that the question will come and
that I'll get it wrong and then I'll get
all of them wrong and then this will be
embarrassing and I'll feel like I
haven't learned anything and I'll have
to really go back to the drawing board I
want this challenge to be a way for me
to prove to myself that I can still do
things like this that I can still learn
new
ideas here's one interesting passage
I've read so far the fractal Dimension
is a measure of the roughness of the
features Earth's natural features are
created by tectonic processes and
Modified by erosion erosion seems to be
scale invariant so its influence is the
same on the small features as it is on
the very large that's why a river
network is an example of a fractal when
the same force of nature acts at
multiple scales we see similar features
appearing I think the lack of yummy food
is actually affecting me more than I
thought it would um when I conceived of
this idea of like just eating beans I
was like yeah yeah sounds good sounds
fine sounds
easy I don't know I don't want too I saw
Bo miles eat a whole bunch of beans that
looks like he ate them cold so I feel
like I
can it's Grim but it's not too bad try
to taste normal okay this is actually
good
maybe maybe I could actually do
this I think maybe a problem that I have
is that often to like start work or you
know to start doing something High hard
I often wait until conditions are
perfect right so like I've eaten
something good it's like not too hot not
too cold I'm feeling not too tired
basically waiting and and doing all
these things in my day to make it feel
perfect and the right conditions before
I even start and I can feel myself
wanting to do that it's like hard to
study right now it's like hard to read
but I actually want to exercise that
muscle of discomfort of pushing through
and doing something hard even when the
conditions aren't perfect for me one
thing I'd like to be able to learn is
how to calculate fractional Dimensions
um as you might know I have a passion
for Dimensions thinking about the fourth
dimension things like this and so the
idea of dimensions in some sense being
these in between spaces between two and
three dimensions um between 1 and two 3
and four maybe um being able to
calculate and understand what it means
to be a fraction Dimension what does it
mean to be
2.5d and lucky for me I've encountered a
pretty simple formula in the book to
measure the fractal Dimension the thing
you are measuring such as the perimeter
or area should be a constant given by
multiplying the total number of
fragments by the size of each one raised
to its Dimension let's take the area of
a square for example it's in one piece
so n is equal to one the length of each
side is one but we're talking about area
which is two dimensional so D is equal
to 2 so the formula will be 1 * 1 to^ 2
which is equal to 1 imagine breaking the
square up into four fragments now n is
equal to 4 and the length of each of the
smaller squares is 1 12 still the
dimension is two so we have 4 * a half
to the^ 2 which is still equal to 1 this
approach can be used to work out the
fraction dimension of any
shape the first question has
arrived okay so this is about the
coastline Paradox which I did read about
all right let me just have a minute
which of the following statements is
true regarding measuring the length of a
cosine with a ruler is the dimensional
less than one I don't think so an
increase of E I thought I don't know I
don't know I actually don't know let's
just see the length of a coine tends to
converge to a single value in D in a
dimension greater than one but no I feel
like none of these is all right okay I'm
panicking I don't know I've got to pick
something I've got to pick something I'm
taking too long I'm taking too long I'm
just going to say a okay because I'm
taking too long here the answer is in
here the answer is
D in a dimension greater than one the
length of a coine remains almost
constant as we decrease the the size of
the ruler okay I've gone back to my book
and found a paragraph that explains why
I got that one wrong but I think it does
clear it up it's this paragraph here
about the fractional Dimensions it says
that the approximate measure in the
dimension D is independent of Epsilon
now Epsilon is the size of the ruler and
the measure in this case is the length
of the coastline so if we can measure
the length of the coastline in the
dimension D which is the fractional
dimension of the coastline then it's
independent of the size of the ruler we
use and the fractional dimension of the
coastline happens to be about
1.26 so it is greater than one so if we
look at our question there is indeed a
dimension greater than one in fact it is
at about
1.26 where the length of the coastline
remains almost constant as we decrease
the size of the ruler a previous reader
of this book even underlined this
section here which is what was stuck in
my brain when answering this question it
is that if you approximate the coast
Line's length in a dimension smaller
than its fractional Dimension then the
length will go to Infinity as the size
of your ruler goes to zero that is the
normal case where we're essentially
using an ordinary one-dimensional ruler
also known as a straight line to measure
the length of the coastline we can't
measure it with these one-dimensional
rulers though we need our rulers to be
1.26 dimensional okay so that was kind
of a lot but I appreciate the question
because I skimmed over some of this
stuff and I guess I didn't really get it
until now I had just thought yeah yeah
Small ruler your length will go to
Infinity not always the case depends on
the dimension of the ruler what's
unfortunate about getting this first
question wrong is that I haven't
received any of the rewards but the
first one that I would receive is fire
and I do have some candles over there
and so that would allow me to get a
little bit of light for studying tonight
yeah that'll kind of ruin my plans of
doing more study tonight if I'm not able
to unlock
this I found a good example of using
that formula to calculate the fractal
dimension of something that is not quite
a line take a line of length one divide
it into three parts of length 1/3 just
keep the two end segments and throw the
rest out so n is equal to 2 now repeat
that process the remaining fragments are
split into to three parts of length 1 9
keep the two ends of each and you now
have four fragments now can we find a
dimension in which the total measure of
the line remains constant we'll just set
these two equations equal to each other
and solve for D doing so results in this
formula with logarithms in it putting in
our numbers we find that the dimension
in which the measure remains constant is
D is equal to log 2 over log 3 which is
0.639 it's less than a line but more
than a point this example is known as a
Cantor set in some porous materials the
distribution of voids can resemble the
process of removing segments similar to
the Cantor set coral reefs grow through
a process of branching which can also
create complex self similar structures
at different scales much like the
iterative removal of segments the
fractal likee growth patterns of coral
allow for efficient use of space and
resources with the intricate branching
increasing surface area for sunlight
absorption and nutrient
exchange this is exciting okay another
chance a chance to save
myself
all right so okay here's the
question which of the following
statements is true regarding the two
definitions of Dimension topological
Dimension and horal dimension so I did
read about this earlier I know that it
can be a fraction and that's where we
get this idea of fractional Dimensions
okay so is it a that the topological
Dimension may be an integer or a
fraction no because I think only the
whole do of one can be a fraction b a
fractal is a set that
satisfies um the horf S Dimension being
bigger than the topological Dimension
that does ring a bell I think I did read
that see the horf S Dimension cannot be
equal to the topological Dimension yeah
that seems consistent wait the hor
Dimension cannot be equal H I'm going to
go with B the answer is in this
one okay the answer is B um so that's
one yay okay we're one F there we've got
a reward okay this is great news because
it is getting a little bit dark soon
still light now but we might have some
candles
tonight
I've got to confess that I am a little
bit afraid of any kind of fire even
lighting candles which is why I'm being
so awkward in these clips and standing
over the
sink these pictures go hard and the
gussian hills that never were would make
for a cool album title but they also
demonstrate that to make video games and
models look the most realistic fractal
should be used in in the simulations I
had my dinner and did some more reading
and then late at night on the first day
the third question arrived let's see
what's in this
one here we go mandelbrot coined the
term fractal because of the following
meaning a fractional Dimensions B it is
a factual way to organize nature C it
was inspired by branching patterns
created during fracking and D is it is
based on the Latin fraus breaking into
irregular fragments I do remember
reading something like this in the
mandal BR book and mandal BR is the guy
who actually came up with the name
fractal um so I believe what he has to
say on the matter so I'll go with d it
is based on the Latin fracus meaning
breaking into irregular fragments I
remember that irregular fragments part
because before today before I was
reading this mandal r book I did think
it was a I thought it was fractional
Dimension but no I'm going to take Mand
br's word on this one so I'll go with d
here is our answer um okay that's good
that's good that's a um boost for the
morale tonight I do get to TI off
something on the board though and that's
going to be this one here which is
writing just to be able to take notes
and I actually get to keep the notes
that I take as a bit of a cheap cheap
it's been hard to study without this
because it feels like just reading for
reading's sake um but I really find it
useful to be able to write down and
organize my thoughts and on that I think
I'm going to go to bed pretty soon just
cuz uh candle light's not quite as easy
as I think the sunlight's going to be so
good
night I got up to take a video of the
deer who was back again but then the
morning got absolutely derailed when I
spotted the spider I had to prop the
side door open a bit to get it out but
from this moment on I was living in fear
and sleeping with one eye open
everywhere I sit I am now on the lookout
for more
spiders I do have one friend on board
their name is be and that stands for
benoir B mandal BR I might try to
explain some Concepts to them later on
uh but for now I'm going to leave them
up here on this curtain rail to uh keep
a watchful eye over me fun fact algebra
derives from the Arabic word meaning the
reunion of broken parts so fractal and
algebra come from opposite
meanings these are the note-taking
implements that I am rewarded with by
getting that last question
right I just saw what I think was two
foxes going past the window so that was
pretty
cool it's nearly 4:00 and I've been
studying all day with no questions
coming through so I've received a heads
up that the next question will be based
on two chapters from a particular book
and it's pretty good that the next chis
is from here cuz I've been reading this
one I found that it has really clicked
with me in a way that the mandal BR book
didn't I had this tiny tinge of
disappointment that I won't walk away
from this challenge feeling like I know
fractals instead I'll be feeling like
there's so much more to learn fractals
are a big topic that impact so many
different fields right I've been reading
some of these books and I'm just amazed
by the amount of different places that
freals show up that I had no idea about
like in this book here there was a
chapter about um fractals like in mining
and gold deposits and I was reading that
chapter and realized that just trying to
understand that chapter could be an
entire challenge video of its own and
that there's definitely entire careers
to be made out of studying fractals and
even just some of the use cases in which
they appear this does kind of make me
feel like I'm cramming I'm sort of bit
of an anxiety that there is a time
pressure that there are questions
arriving any minute and so I'm a little
worried that I will forget a lot of this
content but without doing this I
wouldn't have made much progress through
these books at all so I'm hoping that at
least something sticks um and that at
least some new ideas start to form and
then I can build on them later if I want
to
it's very quiet out here very
still it's a little bit boring in some
sense but in another way there's no
place I'd rather
be here it is I don't want to open it I
feel like I'm not ready like I I want to
feel more prepared um I don't know this
is the state of my cheat sheet of notes
when the question arrived so it wasn't
full I was like still planning to make
some more notes down
here
okay you measure the length of the
coastline of three different Islands
Island X Y and Z using four different
rulers with lengths 10 cm 1 M 100 m and
1 km each ruler gives a different result
and you plot them on a graph which
statement is false this is kind of like
that graph that I showed you yesterday
actually where one of the gradients was
flat and that was for a circle
which isn't fractal at all for a
non-fractal shape it like at least
levels off or is flat the island Zed has
a smoother Coastline than Island y wait
no yeah okay that's the one that's false
I'm going to say
d yeah can't it can't be smoother than
white it just can't it can't be smoother
than
what answer
yes okay okay this is great this is
great I'll also be able to use real
lights from now on um the overhead
lights which is going to be great for my
eyes this is a really small Joy but I
need
it this actually smells great and looks
really good no it actually looks really
good today I like it if I had some
cheese and rice to go with this it
wouldn't be a grim meal at all it would
take be one of my favorite meals the
sooner I can escape the bus and go
outside the better I love being in here
and learning and I love learning about
fractals but you know it hurts to be out
here but then locked in a bus it's like
I'm in nature but so close yet so far to
be honest I think if I was able to go
outside and do walks and do things and
and be more in control of my life I
think I would actually study better I
don't think that all of these hours that
I've spent in here have been productive
hours many of them have been I think
nonproductive I don't think what I'm
doing is the best or far from the only
way to
learn I was just taking a minute to
stare at the ceiling but I heard another
envelope get dropped
off I'm excited but I'm also nervous um
I've still got my same cheat sheet with
me from earlier um okay we can do this
we can do this this should be good all
right I really love opening
these you were taking a random walk when
you notice an oddl look tree examining
one of its leaves you determine it can
be constructed the following way in each
iteration ABC all side lengths are equal
what is the fractal
Dimension I've got a couple of formulas
that help me calculate the fractal
Dimension what I need to know is how
many fragments it's being broken up into
and like the size of each of those
fragments yeah that that would have to
make sense that it's been broken
into one 2
three what I needed to do was just look
at the first order change we started
with four lines of length one then
squares are added into each fragment we
now have 20 lines of length 1/3 since
three fit along the original side put
those numbers into the logarithm formula
to find that D is Log 5 log3 but I
muddled up the bottom and got log 1/3
instead of log 3 this caused me to panic
and enter a tail spin for 20 minutes
trying various other techniques which
would have worked had I not made more
basic errors oh my God eventually I
picked Log 5 over log 3 because I could
tell it was close to my answer in four
and I knew it was in the right ballpark
even if I couldn't explain the
discrepancy yes
yes okay says C I've been subing this
for like half an hour ticking
off
technology and here are my rewards my
phone and my laptop okay I get to use
these and I get to connect to the
internet for the next part I received a
message that the next question would be
about the mandal BR
so I did some Googling and even watched
a few number file videos about it I
found that understanding the mandal BR
set starts with understanding the
behavior of numbers when you square them
some numbers when you square them blow
up and go to Infinity but not all
numbers one stays the same no matter how
many times you square it and numbers
less than one will actually decrease if
you square them the mandle BR set
explores this line between stable and
unstable points where unstable points
are those ones that blow up to Infinity
in particular the mandle set is defined
by this iterative formula that starts at
zero you square it and then add a
complex number onto it to get the
starting point for the next iteration if
C the complex number that you're adding
each time causes the value to blow up to
Infinity then C is not in the mtle BR
set If instead C causes the value to go
to some stable fixed point or to zero
for example then C is in the mandal BR
set to see what I mean let's take a look
at a few numbers and see if they are in
the mandal r set let's take one starting
with 0^ 2 + 1 that's 1 square one and
add one and you get two square that and
add one and you get five square that and
add one and you get 26 and it will keep
going to Infinity so one is not in the
mandal BR set let's let's try I which is
the square < TK of -1 0 + I is I then I
2 + I is equal to -1 + I then square
that and add I and it actually works out
to be just minus I square that and add I
and again you'll get min -1 + I and
you'll continue toggling between these
values so I is in the mandal BR set in
this shape here anywhere that is black
is a point in the mandal set and the
colored points are ones that go off to
Infinity but they're colored based on
how quickly they go off to Infinity it's
a very interesting mathematical pattern
when you zoom in on various parts you
will find the shape repeats it is
fractal because there is repeating
detail and self-similar structures at
every scale it has a fractal dimension
of about 1.3 it's more than a line but
not enough to be a filled in shape it's
amazing the complexity that comes out of
this thing because fundamentally it's
defined by quite a simple rule this
artwork is made by just marking points
that when squared and then added to
themselves in an iterative way remain
stable so I'm feeling a little bit down
actually because I realized that I got
the previous question right but not
because I actually got it right more
that I got it close enough and and
essentially guessed the right answer um
and I've had time to go and think and
realize how it was done and where I
actually made a mistake I used a three
instead of a third anyway and then I I
used something else wrong the second
time so I did all this working and I I
got close enough and I got the answ so
I'm going to allow it and you know
guessing is allowed in in this game I've
designed in the sense that it's
multi-choice for a reason if you don't
know you should have a one and four
chance of getting it right so I got it
right and I'm moving onwards but I feel
like I really had two or more brain
farts in the process of doing that
working out and so for that reason I'm
going to call it quits for today go to
bed and hope that I'm a little bit
fresher and more onto it
tomorrow
I've just got out of bed this morning to
find one more question and this could be
the last
one oh there's no answer in this one
okay visit brilliant.org navigate to
complex numbersthe mandal BR set
complete the final question correctly to
escape the
bus this question is sponsored by
brilliant brilliant is an interactive
way to learn math data science and
computer science what I like about
brilliant is that I get to test my
knowledge by answering questions which
helps me feel like I actually understand
what I'm reading the courses are also
fun and allow you to work at your own
pace their course on complex numbers
covers the mandal BR set and the related
Julia sets by first covering the
properties of complex numbers which are
important to understanding these
particular fractals you can get started
on brilliant for free for 30 days and
the first 200 people get 20% off an
annual plan by visiting brilliant.org
ties if a point C is in the main CARiD
then the process of squaring and adding
eventually results in a single fixed
Point Z such that Z2 + C is equal to Z
if x is a real number in the mandle BR
set what's the maximum value of x like
God this is quite hard 1/2 is the
largest of these numbers so that seemed
like a good place to start initially I
tried to just see what happened if I
squared these numbers and added them
tosel to see if that would be stable or
not but after several iterations of this
mandal BR function I would have a number
that wouldn't really tell me
definitively if it would keep getting
bigger or converge to some fixed value
and so it wasn't clear without doing a
lot more iterations what would be the
long-term behavior of these things so I
ended up using the hint on brilliant
which gave me this equation that z^2 + x
is equal to Z initially I didn't see how
this would help but I realized this is
to do with the fixed Point what I mean
is for numbers that are going into this
mandal BR function either they will blow
up to infinity or they might oscillate
around a stable point a fixed point so
some value that it converts meres to no
matter how many times you put it into
this function in this equation that
fixed point is represented by Z it's
saying that if you've done enough
iterations to reach this final fixed
point then you square it and add your
number on you should end up still at
that fixed point so I just need to find
which one of these four fractions is the
largest one that satisfies this equation
that seems kind of tricky and starting
with putting 0.5 in just to see what
happens we get this quadratic which
actually doesn't have any real solutions
you could try to complete the square or
use the quadratic formula on this but
the only Z that you'd find which
satisfied it would have an imaginary
component so let's try the next biggest
one which is a third putting a third in
leads to the same problem that there is
no real solution for Z in this quadratic
equation the next one to try is one qu
and rearranging it to have z^ 2 - Z + A4
being equal to Zer you could complete
the square quite easily actually and
find a zed value of a half that's pretty
cool and we can see that it works if
you're already at the point one2 or 0.5
and you square that it becomes one4 or
0.25 which is how much you're adding
back on so you're going to end up with
what you started with 0.5 and no matter
how many more iterations of the mandal
BR function you do from this point you
will stay there the largest real number
in the mandal BR set is also the point
on the real axis that is furthest to the
right so this red dot here in the
picture above the question that's what
I'm saying should be one qu and
eyeballing it with the axes that are
given here looks about right too so I'm
going to go with
that I'm nervous because I really want
to go
I wanted to make a graceful and profound
exit like they do on The Bachelor when
they slowly step out of the car instead
this is the exit I
made running in fear from what is
objectively a tiny threat oh my God I
have a big problem on the line this is
the final boss if it jumps on me UND I
ended I'm just going I'm going I'm going
I'm going I'm
going oh my God oh my God craving
something like this for a while how do I
eat
it that's really good I don't think I
became an expert on fractals I think
maybe I learned enough to be able to
sustain a conversation about them but I
feel far from being an expert in fact it
was the simple things that near defeated
me on this challenge logarithms and the
quadratic formula so if anything I could
just spend 3 days out here relearning
the basics of maths but um I'm glad I
did it it was fun to do I look forward
to doing something like this again see
you next time and thank you to my
patreon supporters for making these
videos possible shout out to today's
patreon cats of the day Duchess and
princess